さんこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ただいま深夜の3時です
うん
眠いはい私とっても眠いんですけれども皆
さん
ジグソーパズルというものをご存知
でしょうかこう小さいピースみたいなやつ
たくさんあってそれをこうポツポツ
ポツポツ組み合わせて1つの絵を完成さ
せるパズルというものがあるんですけれど
も世の中にはあら不思議やってはいけない
そういった禁断のパズルというものがある
んですよあの例を一つ出させていただくと
あの遊戯遊戯に出てくる遊戯くんが解いた
千年パズルあれだけはマジで手を出しちゃ
いけないああいうなんか闇の人格が入って
くるみたいなやべえパズルも禁断のパズル
としては存在するんですけども私今回その
中の一つ禁断のパズル持ってきました
こちら
うーん
ラブだね
眠くなるパズル
羊が1匹羊が2匹
眠気に耐えてパズルを組み立てることが
できるのか裏にも色々書いてありますね
眠くなるパズル委員会からの注意そんな
委員会があると一番初心者の方は絶対に
挑戦しないでくださいもうこの時点で禁断
なんですよ僕みたいな素人がやってはいけ
ないパズルなのかもしれません世界最小
ピースは小さくて組むことが困難です
えこれただ羊の映画って眠くなります
みたいなやつじゃないとそもそもの難易度
がやばい
終わったか今日
寝れない3えどのピースも羊羊だらけの超
難易度の柄です
[音楽]
終わったこれ完全に終わったえ俺さ今
めっちゃ眠いんよあの普通にもう今3時半
ぐらいかな普通に限界レベルで眠くて
そして見てくださいこれ世界に通用させる
ために英語表記で書いてあるんですよ
見据えてんなこのパズル世界見せてんな
これこれは禁断でしょそもそも眠くなる
ようなこの行かれたイラストそして世界
最小サイズのピースそれを今から
素人がやります今までありがとうござい
ました早速やってみようと思います開け
ます
[音楽]
ねやばいちょっと見てくださいこれ
ちょっと待って眠いところのレベルじゃ
ないぞこれなんかピースが超細かいんです
けどもこれが世界最小ピースか俺の指と
比べるともう見て爪より小さいピースが
[笑い]
世界最小ピースはこのレベルなのにねまあ
とりあえず開けてみます今回の動画は
そもそもこの眠くなるパズルって本当に
眠くなるのかどうかちょっと検証してみ
たいと思いますあとそもそも難しすぎて
ちょっと不安だわこれ
やば
[音楽]
全部で1000くらいあるらしいですけど
も早速やっていきたいと思いますじゃあ
やっていきましょう
何からやればいいんだこれちょっと待って
本当にやばいぞこれ難易度皆さんこれ結構
普通にやばいですよこのパズルを作るん
ですけど見てください
全員一緒あーでも見てください優しいこの
ジグソーパズルの裏面には図のような4
種類のマークが印刷されておりピースを
分けたりピースの場所を見つけるガイドに
なりますマジ助かるこれがないと無理だ
じゃあとりあえずこのマークごとにこれを
分けていきましょうかまずはそれからだ
[音楽]
コーナー発見
ちょっと待ってこれまじやばいぞ俺さっき
はやばいのに手出したらこれあーちょっと
なくすね普通にこれこれみんなあのねやっ
ちゃいけないやつかもしれないこれ寝れ
なくなるとかそういう次元じゃなくて多分
人が手を出したらいけないタイプのやつ
ですね
パズルはまずはとりあえず外装から
固めるのが大事だからまずそこよな
おおおお
初めて揃った
わかんないけど多分これ
初めて食べましたねこのレベルです
全部
羊の毛これを1000ベース繋げなきゃ
いけません
[音楽]
外れます進めてるんですけどもひょっとし
たらバツで寝てしまうかもしれない
もちろん寝たら動画終了です寝ちゃったか
どうかの判定する人がいないので僕が起き
ているのか起きてないのか寝てしまって
いるのか
判定してくださる超スペシャル大物ゲスト
お呼びしておりますどうぞ
うわーすごいどうもパズルといったらこの
俺パズル&ドラゴンズのプロデューサー
山本大輔ですうわ大家先生よろしくお願い
しますありがとうございますお願いします
いつもも楽しませております
か本当にありがとうございますいつも本当
っすか次のコラボ何にするんですかパズ
ドラ
ギアですねドラゴンボールとしますもうし
てます
許してくださいというわけで山本
プロデューサーには僕が寝てしまったら
123で3カウント立っても動かなかっ
たら終わりで大丈夫ですよろしくお願いし
ますよろしくお願いしますじゃあ行きます
やっぱちょっと待ってよこれ結構やばいぞ
普通にこれちょっと油断したら寝ますわ
マジで眠気が来る
ちょっと待ってやばいちょっと待ってくれ
よ目がもうこれね
普通にね今
お布団で寝たい
[音楽]
な
あーいいですね
あともうちょっと全然違うだろまだ早いよ
ねでもこのなんか
毛の感じ似てんだよなここら辺
わかるこれちょっと雑な毛のあーなるほど
写真で撮ってるからピントもずれるわけよ
確かに近い羊と糖質自体とクッキーさが
違うからそういう部分からなんとなく
見つけてゆく
ありがとうそれができない
[音楽]
だいぶ行ったっすね
見えてきてる見えてはないんだよ何にも
見えてないんだよ
[音楽]
すごい1時間半かけて1/4の周りだけ
なんとかできましたで普通にこれちょっと
合ってるかもわかんないんですけど多分
あってますなんか微妙な羊の目とか鼻とか
の形を意識してなんとか作ってみました
全部同じ
これとこれのさ違いわかる皆さんこれマジ
でやばい見てくださいこの3つのピース
これ何が違うか分かりますか
僕には分かりません
[音楽]
全部一緒やんなんかその面白いとか言っ
てるわけじゃなくて本当に全部一緒なん
ですよこれ
[音楽]
やめたそうです
終了
です
はじめさん
完全に行きました
もう3秒経ちました目つぶってから
2時間ぐらいやってみたんですけど
情けねえな時間でこれか
[音楽]
はいやばい
さすがにないよね
これが目だとしたらほら
素晴らしい
オックスフォード大学出身
すごいなマサチューセッツ工科大学出身
だろう
ほら見てくださいほらどこで見つけたの
この辺にありました
素晴らしいありがとうございます試験
免除よし
[音楽]
よし白っぽい
まだこの辺ごり寄せそうだな
休憩しますお願いします
ちょっと待ってちょっと待って
[音楽]
すごいすごい
この終わりかけが
ちょっと待って本当に見えてますちょっと
急いで早くそっち回りたい
[音楽]
時間が近づいてまいりました
あと5個だあと5個だやばいよだれ止まら
ん
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばい
ラストです
え
入らない間違えてた雨間違ってた1個
[音楽]
これつなげて完成だ
はいというわけで
約1週間かけて10人ぐらいの人の力を
借りてようやく完成しました
[音楽]
マジでつらかったちょっと待ってね
ちょっと眠くなる難しいパズルかなと思っ
てやってるんですけども本当に難しくて
ちょっと素人の手には負えないレベルの
難しさ一人じゃ絶対できないなと思って
2人でやってたんですけどそれも無理で
もう最終的に10人ぐらいでやってたん
ですけどそれでも1週間ほどかかって
しまってなんか俺多分2月の最初ほぼ動画
出してなかったと思うんですけどもこれ
編集する間もなくずっとパズルやってて
なんか俺何やってんだろうと思って本当に
普通にでも仕上げたくてどうしても仕上げ
たくてちょっと全てを犠牲にしてパズルを
やった1週間でしたなんかいろんな
ジグソーパズル今までやってきたんです
けどもちょっと本当に
比べ物にならないくらい難しかったです
これ眠くなるパズルではなく
勘違いで眠るパズル
永遠の死を意味しますいやもうマジでき
つかった1週間全部これに使ったからね俺
は
マジで本当にいろんな人に協力してもらっ
てみんなで力を合わせて朝も晩もパズルを
費やした1週間でしたもうこの羊のパズ
ドラ本当に大事ですもうこれはマジで崩し
たくないちょっと額縁とかに入れて家に
飾っておきたいと思います
めっちゃ大事
[音楽]